kamala harris mostly silent after
bragging about her role in helping shape
joe biden's disastrous afghanistan
withdrawal
he just made a really big decision
afghanistan yes
were you the last person in the room yes
and you feel comfortable i do he is
someone
who i have seen over and over again
make decisions
based on what he truly believes based on
his years of doing this work and
studying these issues what he truly
believes is the right thing to do
that did not age well and it's only a
couple days old
kamala did manage to tweet for two
decades our courageous service members
put their lives on the line in
afghanistan we will always be grateful
and proud ending u.s military
involvement in afghanistan is the right
decision kennedy isn't that kind of the
straw the straw man argument no one
it's a goo you know
it's a convincing argument to leave
afghanistan that's what no one's upset
about that it's how it was done how
botched it was yeah that's like everyone
agrees that we should free brittany yes
no one thinks that we should push her
dad off a bridge exactly there's a very
big difference she is wrong on
everything and you know she's she's so
narcissistic and why didn't she take the
call sheet from joe and go down it to
dana's point and start calling foreign
leaders you know she she is the vice
president of the united states and she
is certainly not taking a leadership
role here which is also no surprise yes
all right dana what's really going on
what's going on behind the scenes i feel
like something is going on something is
up i don't know what it is but something
i smell some kind of thing and it's not
gas yes
i'm glad you clarified yes
um
do you remember at the beginning of the
administration um the
uh i was going to call him the prime
minister ron claimed that
he um
they had kamala harris do all these
world leader calls do you guys remember
this yeah that was weird
and so she was making relationships she
was building up a partnership with all
these people and then you at the
briefing today you find out that
president biden hasn't called anyone we
just found out in the commercial break
that the white house has just alerted
the world that after that briefing where
they said the president had not spoken
to any other world leader for the last
several days he has now spoken to boris
johnson of the uk so take that for what
it's worth also i have to imagine that
the women's groups and the human rights
groups have to be thinking that they
could have expected more from the first
woman vice president historically at
least maybe say something
a woman of color no less a woman of
color first female vp
mum on the situation for afghan women
geraldo how's your hero now
which one are you referring to uh you
know i always go to erica
when i i want to speak about a woman in
the leadership role because it's very
easy
to say oh they come off as nasty or
they're overbearing eric cocaine you
know i think they they're my wife yeah
that's right all my children
she is named after erica kane
[Laughter]
but i i really think she's in a very
tough spot and i don't know
how competent
she is in this role she was she was
pretty good as a senator and a d.a and
an attorney general but i'm not sure how
good she is and it's a very difficult
role and joe biden was a great vice
president kamala harris so far has been
a pretty mediocre vice president you're
being quite diplomatic jessie uh could
it be she's out of the picture to
preserve her brand like she's like don't
get she doesn't want her fingerprints on
this now she's hi she's in hiding maybe
yeah unlike geraldo i don't consult my
wife before i talk about women's issues
on television maybe you should maybe i
should maybe i should but now kamala has
become the laughing stock that joe was
when he was vice president and so she
has three options because this is a
loyalty test right now number one option
she could come out and she could
be a good vp and say you know what it
was trump's fault it was the afghan
army's fault and she could really show
joe that she has his back number two
you leak
and you leak that you know what i had
some questions about this execution and
no one listened to me maybe it was a
sexism thing and you get that out there
kind of risky or she just goes silent
she goes silent for about a month and
then she does a softball and she gets
the cameras to film her
hugging afghan women as they arrive at
the tarmac here in the united states
that's her only option she embraces that
i saved your life woman yeah because i
am a strong woman and that's her play
now when she does that she'll have to
credit you yes
she's watching i know hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else